probably 95 percent if not 100 of the
Iranians are listening to Passion
speaking media outside Iran so it's a
BBC
Persian there is Iran International
there are at least five or six of them
that's probably really important to
highlight that
Iran is a very modern and tech savvy
Nation
not just the young people probably more
than more than I feel sometimes when I
compare myself to what they are doing
yeah since 1979 the earlier years for a
decade or two
they tried in a very crude fashion to
restrict and access to Media outside
Iran and because this is all through
dishes okay and satellite dishes are
everywhere you know if you look at the
uh you know
buildings of either a small house small
towns and villages in Iran there's
always a a dish and they watch all kinds
of things through this and particularly
because of what's Happening Now they
listen to all the news
broadcasts from all this media and
they're extremely active
they are
um probably some of them even 24 hours
or close very extensive coverage of
every clip that comes through
so what the government is doing now the
Islamic Republic is that they restrict
the entire internet
they shut that internet but they cannot
afford shutting down the internet
because much of the business much of the
everyday life much of the government
Affairs depends on the internet like
everywhere else and Iran is extremely if
you if I hear from many of the
colleagues and friends you know it's
like in certain districts it's like
Sweden where you go there there's no
more currency and for a very good reason
because there's so much inflation that
that the banknotes are worthless in a
sense so everything is true you know
sweeping your cards and that's the
entire system is in a standstill because
people cannot buy food they can you you
go to the supermarket that's how you
would do it you you order food to come
to your house which Iranians at least
the middle classes the more prosperously
that Christ is doing all the time so
they deliver everything and because of
the covet it became even more and they
have to pay all through this system
um so what happens is that now they're
estimating that every day 50 million
dollars the Iranian government or the
Iranian economy is losing because of
slowing the internet plus the
frustration is growing of course because
you can't order food
WhatsApp yeah every Iranian
virtually every Iranian yeah that has
education and education in the sense
that has gone through
the the high schools and universities
knows how to use the WhatsApp so there's
a big middle class like you said secular
passing around and there there's a lot
of at least capacity for if not
Revolution then
um political ideological
uh
turmoil and the huge amount of hatred
so the hatred is growing yes hatred of
the of the policies
of the regime of isolation that's a huge
point that you hear a great deal about
that we don't want to be isolated we
don't want to be humiliated Iran is not
about
this this miserable regime that is
ruling over us
we have a great culture so there's a
sense of a pride
in their own culture some of its uh you
know Islamic some of it pre-islamic so
they there is a huge um a sense of a
pride in that